this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by mint mobile purple and fitbod
more on that later let's get into the
duke the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media i want to remind you that the
night pants nation tour kicks off next
month september 16th through the 18th in
phoenix all right go to ryanstickler.com
get your tickets we have a bunch of
dates now we're adding a lot more coming
to it all right so like i said september
16th through the 18th i'm in phoenix
september 30th to october 2nd i'm in
indianapolis i'm in vegas with segora
october 8th and 9th i'm doing baltimore
october 23rd brea california october
28th arlington virginia november 10th
through the 13th cleveland ohio december
9th through the 11th and la jolla
december 17th through the 19th those are
my 2021 dates i do have 2022 dates on
the books i'm coming to austin i'm
coming to kansas city vancouver edmonton
go check ryanciclar.com for the tour
dates and wear your night pants nation
uh
pants and if you don't have them come
buy them at the show because we're gonna
be having some late pants nation pants
there y'all um join the email list
please go to my website ryancichler.com
get on that email list you'll be the
first to know a lot of different stuff
going on and subscribe to the youtube
i'm saying please it means nothing to
you and everything to us hit that
youtube you're watching just hit
subscribe it helps us big time all right
and it's free and uh the patreon all
right i love
this [ __ ] show okay the honeydew with
y'all
is such a great show we're out there
talking to everybody about the wildest
[ __ ] you can't even i can't even make it
up i mean just watch the promos on my
social and if that's not enough man i
don't know what the hell to do uh you
get the honeydew a day early ad free at
no additional cost you get the entire
back catalog video and audio option
all right and if you sign up for a year
you get over a month free that's the
best i can do right now and uh if you or
someone you know has that story that has
to be heard hey honeydew honeydewpodcast
gmail.com send them in hopefully we get
to do an uh episode together
the ringtones are they're popping off
like crazy i know you're out there
probably scaring people with them but
they're available on itunes just search
my name on the itunes store not the
podcast app the itunes store
scroll down
ringtones boom there they are we're
working on getting the android ones uh
up on my website now
and uh my athletes we got four right now
going we got marcus everett my bow
fisherman right here we got kaden wood
my d2 pitcher at seton hill we got beck
adler my big wave surfer and maverick
reed my cowboy all right that's all the
new info i wanted to get this out to you
and be current with it because we
recorded this episode a little while ago
so that's all the updates now let's do
the dupe
we are highlighting the low lights you
know where you are girl these are the
stories behind the storytellers today's
storyteller is actually back on the
honeydew for the second time ladies and
gentlemen please welcome eleanor
kerrigan y'all welcome back to the
honeydew girl i'm wearing my drawing i
love it it's a wawa john shout out to
the camera that thing's fair
title idiot i'm sorry i just
my little tic tac tits are out i went to
hug you for the wawa shirt and then i
realized it was john and hug to tighter
you're like oh
[ __ ]
that's my jaw man
yeah i love this
shirt please promote everything and
anything you'd like uh
you're okay they're doing it so wherever
they can find you on the road not just
your dates but where they go to find
those dates okay so i have a website but
i don't know how to um upload anything
so i apologize in advance i'm trying to
sleep with millennials again but then
now that kovid's coming out you know i
got a 35 capacity i can let inside
so
i'm gonna try to get some young folk to
help me fix it okay and um but i am
doing may 21st 22nd 23rd at the la jolla
comedy store very excited about that and
um
one of my favorite things is also i'm
doing reno the laugh factory
in june i'm going to mess up these dates
because i'm terrible at life but i think
it's the
19th
that weekend okay and guess who my
feature is who
the great brian holtzman ladies and
gentlemen
and see me not be able to follow my
feature bring it on out guys bring it on
out
i got the craziest man alive you really
do featuring for me i'm
i'm embarrassed and excited at the same
time because he should be headlining but
so should you i know and i but i do the
world more than him so he
that'll be that is hard that is a nude
new thing to him so it's like you know
and he does hours at the store like he
they put him on last him and brody were
the two
last
got you know they would let them do like
i think brody would do like almost two
hours sometimes you know he took like a
podcast
and a drum session and then holtzman
would do the same thing but they would
fluctuate that time so
we'll see it's going to be fun you're a
comedy store historian i really do love
like anytime i want to know anything i
go to you and like what's the real
[ __ ] deal with this [ __ ] you're like
you know you go back what
to the 93 93
93 and when you said comedy store
historian i don't get in there until 99
didn't you start la jolla first no i
started i started in the belly room back
in the sunday night adam barnhart shows
to where there would be like ten people
and they would go for [ __ ] three and
a half hours of course adam was
stretching haters yeah those guys back
then
and then we talked about it i went
through the tommy days which is why i
never got in you know there's always
some [ __ ] why do i put you in la
jolla
never i've done la jolla i'm a mess
maybe maybe that's where i saw you first
i don't know no i'd only ever done the
holy one i've only still ever done the
holiday once
damn i put you always with somebody else
then that's rude to mix up white guys
like that but i'll do that because i'm
racist so
uh yeah i did um i started 93 but when
you said comedy store historian that to
me that's jeff scott unfortunately we
lost jeff our piano player that is true
um jeff came in uh i think 95 because i
had already been there and we had
another guy named steve moore who was a
house pianist for a long time and then
jeff came in and just when you find
somebody that loves the store like that
it's like oh it's okay because most
people come in they're like i'm better
than this place i'm this i'm not
and it's you're not it's history it's
it's a weird rich it's a weird history
it's some [ __ ] up history are we
allowed to curse on this anyway uh i
already ruined that didn't i tic tic tac
tits
this little pet name that dice gave me
on the road which is awesome it's
awesome yeah
um but i want to say thank you because
you i say you're you're back here but
when you first did your episode we were
literally at my kitchen table was three
number three right that's right number
three in my apartment yeah and i was
like look we're you know
tom's still building the studio out this
thing's gonna go you're like this
[ __ ] is doing a show at his
apartment
i wasn't i was like this is awesome i
wish i had a kitchen table like this
josh was with us josh out of myers and
now look where we are right without josh
which is amazing that means we moved
smart move we moved up
you also he's going to call me about
that dude like [ __ ] josh no uh he also
uh when you were doing your
announcements you said monday mm-hmm i
would i merely jumped over the table to
fight you it was so good
monday
monday we have audio monday video on
tuesday don't you know about it that's
how my grandmother that's how everybody
over there talks it's true baltimore and
philly have similar eyes they're cousins
they're cousins definitely similar
accents and i didn't know that until
later because why would i talk to
anybody from baltimore and uh baldy
moore but not until i moved out to la
did i meet
somebody from you know and then she
became a good friend and i was like damn
she sounds like me and they were like oh
are you from baltimore i'm like no i'm
from south philly i'll [ __ ] fight you
right now but
i'm working on you i'm getting it wrong
yeah i'm working on the anger let's talk
about that because you're one of 10 kids
all right so if you don't know if you've
never heard go listen to eleanor's first
episode also her craft feast oh the crab
feast god damn great too and i always
pump the crab feast it's a it's a
library of seven years of such great
guests and great stories i still get um
hit up online about the crab feast cause
we talked about the tiger oh god they
have tigers so people send me
pictures of the rifle and the tigers i
know that um
i want to say since you told me about
that being able to have a pet tiger up
until certain whatever there's been two
or three other people who've floated
into my life that have okay through this
podcast or somewhere else that i wished
it on you i willed it
all i like you guys happen to know
eleanor carrick
like no no
it is weird i didn't you were the tiger
king before tiger king oh my god how
great is tiger king right
you guys were doing that [ __ ] they just
kept going with it well people if there
was a place like that out in
pennsylvania like out and apparently all
the animals got out on the freeway or
some of the highway or whatever tires
and [ __ ] yeah this happened
100
and we think that our tony our tigger
you know because they gave him it got so
bad ripping up the furniture and
everything they were tiger
really you can't tame them anyway it's
ripping up there in a row
you can't
you can't be like get off the furniture
get down get down your neighbor had a
pet tiger in a philadelphia row home it
is insane every time i walk by
the the street and i see the back of my
friend frankie's house i'm like how
little it is so little so little this
big this is it the fence like this yeah
two other dogs
and that's that's not good
no
it was a baby it got along and the only
person of course that it you know
lived on and like cuddled up to was my
brother charlie naturally charlie
charlie i made you say it
jungle books
[Laughter]
dr doolittle's out there just walking
around with all his animals
even when we were kids like dogs would
like stray dogs we'd be like let's go
feed the dog i'm like we don't feed our
dog like we don't have food
why are we giving food away to another
dog but like charlie be like i feel bad
for him you know
so he did that
our dog we i don't know if i talked
about fluffy did i sure i don't remember
so please fluffy is i don't remember
it's good that you get high
and it's all new to me
this is brand new
you hear about fluffy
i i my favorite one of my favorite
moments telling a fluffy story was i did
bill burr's um
the ringers
where he put comics on like almost like
a danger field thing but he did it on
comedy central so he had to be clean
which was terrifying for me but whatever
he interviewed us i saw before okay so
we talked about fluffy and when my mom
was taking us to this flyers game
because i told the story about
she was just
had it like she's standing in the middle
i told it on the the crab feet is this
the one where in the blizzard where
she's dragging you yes i told you i just
told the story the other day to a friend
like in the middle of a blizzard she's
dragging her children down the only time
they're ever going to get free hot
chocolate those seats too
with the street bullies
my mother was like wrap them up
pulling the sled sledding her children
and but when we were going we saw this
like thing come out of a snow drift and
it was fluffy covered in snow i just
popped out of a snow drift
and i was telling bird the story of bill
goes oh man back when dogs could be dogs
yeah right yeah and i was like oh yeah
yeah yeah dogs would just roam
the neighborhood like i had people knew
who the dog was well that's the best
part yeah i have nine brothers and
sisters so i'm always jimmy's sister
karen sister bobby's sister edie's you
know always somebody sister right and i
was walking to school one day i was in
high school and the neighbor goes oh hey
there's fluffy's sister and i'm like
that's it
that's it
you son of a [ __ ]
that's how popular fluffy was
everybody knew fluffy and she would she
was a little racist i don't know who
taught her about
racist dogs not teach this dog
but i remember coming home from school
and uh these i see these two little
black girls there was like a curly slide
and they were up at the top and i'm like
why are they screaming and i and i was
like genuinely concerned walking home
from school like
it's what the hell is wrong and they're
ah help us and i'm i'm looking i don't
see anybody around and then all of a
sudden i see fluffy running
he's terrorized he's got them at the top
wait fluffy's a he she
i'm sorry
did i say he oh i'm sorry babe that's my
girl fluffy
she was it was in between she was trans
so
you know
we don't know what she identified as but
she was going back and forth back and
forth and and these poor kids are up at
the start i'm like god damn it this dog
so i go across the street and get him
and they were like that dog tried to
kill us and i'm like i'm so sorry but
you if you if you i don't know if she
was racist or if like
it was fear like if she sends fear
because she bit a lot of people see oh
she was a biter neighborhood fighter if
they were afraid of the dog she bit them
so she like if they did anything if they
were like
she was like
i'll show you what to be afraid of
want something to be afraid of
so i'm going to say my dad anger and
your whole family all the way down into
the pets
i'm going to say my dad trained her
want me to show you what anger is
[Laughter]
you afraid i'll show you to be afraid
that's not a way
but i i cause my dad did that's when he
left and then we were just stuck with
her but this dog
she knew the neighborhood in and out and
like one night i remember these kids
were trying to steal our bikes
and me and billy of course the two
terrible kids together up because as
soon as my mom would go to sleep we'd be
like let's go and we go downstairs or
we'd go outside and play hockey and we
were like
nine ten you know just outside and my
poor mother
was working
trying to feed 10 children no support
from cuckoo's nest
and
so
you know uh she's doing this as soon as
she went to sleep she was she was passed
she died you know she was like i'm not
waking up i don't care if you guys are
on fire don't bother me you know so we
would sneak down and we heard something
it was and our bikes were broken so if
you were picking we were those were
already scraps other people they were
already stuck okay maybe
okay maybe
but it was usually like a cousin that
would come back and be like i'm sure one
of the kerrigan kids needs a bike you
know but we didn't have locks for it
so they were just powered up never
remember like until my adult life i've i
never locked the bike up no never no i
just remember throwing it on the ground
leave it there
but it did again
one time we only had a bike stolen
that's what i'm saying and because we're
all we grew up in a nice neighborhood
it's an okay neighborhood but if you
took it chances are we we were going to
see you riding it or someone we knew was
going to see you riding it you had to
come from somewhere else to get a bike
yeah that's what they would do yeah it
was well we had the projects the
playground and then our neighborhood so
it was like we would meet in the name in
the middle and fight each other or
from just other neighborhoods coming
down into our neighborhood and
we didn't go in other people's
neighborhoods back then so you know you
if this was where you're from
and you venture out you're on your own
so
whatever i did venture out a lot but
those kids would come and try to but
what these two kids specifically um
they were in the yard we heard them and
they must have been going through it
because our yard looked like sanford and
son you know it was a problem there was
all kinds of broken [ __ ] out there you
know and so uh they must have been going
through it and then fluffy was like
and i was like let's let her out see
what happens and we let her out and i
never saw two and they were young i've
never seen kids not put their feet to
climb the fence
it was a
and they up and ran and fluffy chased
them all the way back
she didn't come back for hours like
these poor kids
i hope they're still alive i it's not my
business but it was a long time ago
a little fluffy out there and she and
she was a sheep and poodle she wasn't
even like a a rottweiler or something
you know like a scary dog she was
she was a fluffy dog
but she would
i remember we all went to my sister
karen the favorite uh which reminds me i
have to tell you what happened um so we
all went to her house which was like
four blocks away because my dad the
house only child your dad will have hang
out 100 percent and by the way it was
his house she was living in he gave it
to her we got it
no kidding she bought it she bought it
okay
it was for sale but he wouldn't sell it
to you guys
i'm sure he gave her a discount but her
and her husband were either renting or
buying i forget but it was my grandmom's
house
my dad's mom and then my mom's mom lived
right up the street from there so that
my mom and dad grew up one street apart
so we were at we it was thanksgiving we
go to her house and we left fluffy at
home well this [ __ ] was like i'm not
staying here with no food and i don't
i'm gonna be honest you talk about not
locking bikes
i don't even think we had a lock on our
front door it was like if you come in
that's on you
yeah you now made a fatal mistake 11 of
you in there yeah of walking in to a
tribe and you don't know who's sleeping
over because my brother jimmy all his
friends used to get kicked out of their
house so he would just have them
sleeping randomly like the rizzos were
always there like jimmy rizzo always he
would eat my mom's lunch
and then for her work
like the lunch she made the night before
oh my god and she'd be like god damn it
but if my mom said she's like at least
they're not out stealing cars so at
least they're here so she would go to
work and she
and i remember and jimmy we were so
close with the rizzos like i grew up
with david bobby group and mike you know
johnny grew up with chrissy like it was
just how it worked and so we my mom knew
their parents too they grew up together
that's how neighborhoodie it was
and so jimmy was like hey that
that egg salad was good
and my mom's like you ate it you
so it was like that but
you know um you never knew what you were
coming into so i don't ever remember
locking the doors but fluffy could
figure out how to get out
and she was scratching on my sister's
door she knew where you all went she
walked she went to my grandmom's
she used to walk my mom's mom would walk
by herself they never drove my mom never
drove my her mom never drove she would
walk my grandma would leave come over
hang out with us whatever she's probably
babysitting who knows and fluffy would
walk her home all the way to the house
and walk back by herself
no [ __ ] and everybody knew fluff you'd
be like hey floppy's you like they got
any biscuits or food because they they
don't have a she's a tiger
she never i don't know fluffy bet the
tiger
that's interesting to think of because
fluffy was always around us got a tiger
attitude 100
but she was probably busy she also uh
played with this dog
she became friendly with this dog
blackie
and blackie
uh lived like so wait next to the
gifagliones
that's the best last name in history of
last names
the jafaglions the steve as steve simone
would say here's your sign greatest last
name ever
but wait fluffy like the dog named
blackie was blackie black yes well then
fluffy wasn't racist right she just if
you didn't like people if you yeah but a
lot a lot of times like black people get
that dog away from me and they would get
fear and she would go after i got one
here we go here we go
but in fairness to fluffy she also bit
michael mulville and uh carol rawlings
so white people yeah okay yeah those are
white names
mobile's a white name
but yeah she uh
so whatever but this thing um wait what
was i just telling you about my brain
went oh with her going to my sister's
house walking my grandma home oh with
blackie
so
she would go
with blackie and my mom would be like
running late for work and she's like as
long as the kids are at school make sure
you're in school you know she would run
to her job she worked for the
philadelphia navy shipyard and she'd go
walk to the bus
and as she's walking to the bus
blackie the dad and fluffy would be
there and fluffy the guy had fluffy on a
leash my mom's like
the guy goes don't worry she doesn't
bite my mom's like yeah i know
she ignored her and she i mean she
probably wasn't like barking like
yeah yeah yeah that's my that's the lady
it doesn't feed me that's the owner is
that my
and so a poor thing and my mom just
walked by and
went on the bus and was like
fluffy was out and they have her on
elite she got pregnant by that dog
fluffy is too much what a [ __ ]
i'm not poor babe i don't know how to
get rid of the babies that is
an
abortion [ __ ] dog and now the dog's
got puppies like this house is horny i'm
going out to get some
there's too many kids oh my god your
[ __ ] life let's take a quick break
and tell you about our first sponsor
mint mobile after years of fine print
contracts and getting ripped off by big
wireless providers if we've learned
anything it's that there's always a
catch so when i first heard that mint
mobile offers premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month
i thought what's the catch but after
speaking with them and using their
service it all made sense there isn't
one mint mobile secret sauce is that
they're the first company to sell
wireless service online only by cutting
out retail stores there's no crazy
overhead costs that get passed down to
you in the form of mystery fees instead
mint just passes on sweet savings direct
to you for people looking for extra
savings mint mobile offers premium
wireless for just 15 bucks a month all
plans come with unlimited talk and text
and high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network use your own
phone with any mint mobile plan and keep
your same phone number along with all
your existing contacts and if you're not
100 satisfied mint mobile has you
covered with their seven day money back
guarantee to get your new wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month and get the
plan shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com
honeydew that's mint mobile.com honeydew
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mittmobile.com
honeydew our next sponsor is purple it
doesn't seem like the world's against us
from getting a good night's sleep this
time of year but when you have a purple
mattress you can sleep cool and
comfortable no matter what the world
throws at you that's because only purple
mattresses have the grid its unique
ventilated design allows air to flow
through to help you sleep cool even when
it feels like a thousand degrees out and
the grid is amazingly supportive for
your back and legs while cushioning your
shoulders neck and hips no matter how
you sleep unlike memory foam which
remembers everything the grid bounces
back as you move and shift so you never
get that i'm stuck feeling you do with
memory foam i'll tell you what i love
too i got the purple pillow i sleep on
it every night i love it it keeps me
nice and cool it's good support i'm a
side sleeper it's a great pillow for
that all right so here's what you can do
you can try your purple mattress risk
free with free shipping and returns
financing is available too
purple is comfort reinvented so right
now you can get 10 off any order of 200
bucks or more go to purple.com honeydew
and use promo code honeydew that's
purple.com
honeydew promo code honeydew for 10 off
any order of 200 or more purple.com
honeydew promo code honeydew terms apply
our next sponsor is fit bod don't get
stuck doing the same workouts making
progress towards the future you means
overcoming new challenges fitbog creates
a fitness program that continually
adapts with new exercises and dynamic
intensity that adjust to how you're
progressing so you'll be challenged to
meet your goals at your own pace alright
there's no perfect body that everyone
can achieve but what we can do is
continually to become a better version
of ourselves all right no workout is one
size fits all so fitbot creates a
fitness program that continually adapts
to you so you stay challenged with new
exercises pacing and intensity based on
where you are and what you want to be
all right so i've already lost about 15
pounds now i like to say 16 because it's
one pound more but it's about that um
and i've been working out and i've been
staying healthy and i've downloaded the
app on my phone it's super easy to use
um and i've been using it and i love it
i'm gonna tell you you can pick workouts
that are tailored towards your equipment
and goals so like if i'm on the road and
i don't have a gym i can find
uh equipment in there or workouts on
there
to do without equipment all right um i
usually get bored i'm always chest try
you know and with fitbod it's constantly
uh reinventing the workout so i don't
have to get bored all right so whether
you're exercising three days a week or
twice a day every workout is
scientifically proven to be better than
the last and fitbit workouts are
balanced to avoid overworking muscles
with varied exercises to keep you sharp
like i said no equipment
no worries fitbot has body weight
routines for those looking to get fit at
home or on the go fitbot is super easy
to use and even has hd video tutorials
to make learning new exercises a breeze
alright pick up the pace on your fitness
journey with fitbod today and your
future self will thank you get 25 off
your membership at fit bod dot me slash
honeydew that's 25 off at fit bod dot me
slash honeydew so when people are like
oh why did you move to l.a i'm like you
come over you come over for a minute
well i always think of you whenever i
see people who are
you know soft or or any of these people
that [ __ ] about something i told you a
little story before here and you're like
and i'm like this girl heard that [ __ ]
and she quit the job and you're like i
want to sat there and talked to him for
three to four hours and i'm like that's
exactly i mentioned you like eleanor
would talk to this guy
so you mentioned also like
you said i'm working on my anger and i
know you're half joking so
i know but you mean working on it
working on it yeah i let it out that's
the part you're joking on uh but i know
you have anger can we talk about like
because you're so familiar
to me your way is
like i watch you and dice on the way you
talk to one another but also i know like
with your brothers you're like you don't
have time for the [ __ ] no you don't
have time for the [ __ ] [ __ ] and
it's a lot of [ __ ] you've done that
so i've always respected that about you
um but where why do you feel like
because i know i'm angry i mean what was
was it that your dad left what was it
that really got you into being just like
[ __ ] pissed about things
i don't i don't know i just i know that
like my mom
would be like just don't break anything
up here you know like i could break
stuff that was already broken in the
yard because i would
my little brother bobby makes fun of me
because if i mean it would be the
dumbest things that i get angry about so
i always try to figure out why would
that make you angry or
why did you get to that level so i'll be
blow drying my hair right and i have big
curly crazy hair so beautiful it is not
a easy tame right so i'm like learning
how to tame this thing and it wasn't
working and i just
and this is at my mother's house
where i'm sure somebody was in the
shower
because that's our bathroom you know
somebody could be going
taking a [ __ ] somebody taking a shower
and somebody's blown away about that too
like it's a row home what did you have
did you have two no well one and a half
one and a half okay so thank god right
but there was times where i'm in the
shower jimmy's shaving johnny's taking a
[ __ ]
and we're all in this room right
so
that could be you know that stench or
never having jimmy appearing
no i'm just kidding
he always used to joke he's like come on
i'll give you a piece of gum come on
come on
he was kidding
but he's just jimmy's a pervert and open
about it you know he'll be like oh look
at that like he'll be like damn that
girl's hot and his daughter will be like
dad she's my age you
know my fault
and then i'll go but look at her look at
the girl look at the girl
am i wrong hey hang on but he doesn't
touch he's more of a talker you know
like uh
without them not to them so much he's
somebody that um no he would have he
would he's somebody that likes that girl
would get offended by
or whomever we were the person would get
offended by
um
because like even when he would come
visit
i was living with my roommate chris we
lived together for 12 years out here he
was my best friend
we both saw [ __ ] so we were
[Music]
we were one
and so we got along great like amazing
and we were polar opposites in that like
he was a mourning person like a child i
know those people yeah
and he used to [ __ ] with me and he'd
open the door and go good morning
good morning i'm like i'll take your
life
away from you you know don't do and so
he would laugh and then slam the door
and like run away like we
close tight
so whatever we're still tight to this
day so chris
um he goes el i think somebody's outside
calling you
and i'm like what do you mean and we
lived like over the garage we had like a
little cute little balcony
and then
he pulled up and this person pulls up in
the like in the driveway and he's like
titty
titty titties yelling and he goes i
think it's for you
so i go outside it's my brother jimmy
i know
but
like chris was like i
a lot of people might get upset down
there oh my god i'm like no that's
amazing just yelling but that's who
jimmy is whatever so i
would go back to the bathroom like
with bobby i was blow-drying my hair i
don't know where bobby was if he was
like in the shower getting out of the
shower who knows you know and it was
tiny it's a tiny little oh yeah i had
one
you know it's
not even half the size of this room it's
even closer yeah it's probably from you
to the wall and so and so anyway so i i
was go [ __ ] i must have had a date or
something who knows i was probably
trying to get some and i'm blow drying
my hair and it's not working i went
mother [ __ ] and i threw the blow dryer
through the medicine cabinet which is
glass yeah the mirror
shatters and bobby goes
now how are you gonna fix your hair you
[ __ ] idiot and he just walked away
and i was just like but like that's a
normal occurrence there's shattered
glass everywhere and it's just like all
right i'll go in the other room to
and
we all did it i mean maybe bobby did i
don't know i know i'm bad i've punched
through things
jimmy has broken
things yeah he punched my share of walls
when i was younger for sure did you
fight a lot growing up like i fought a
ton i was in a ton of fights
especially at you know 16 17 after my
dad died we were on our own oh [ __ ] if
if you know if you brushed against me
the wrong way i was ready to go oh yeah
i loved it that's the other thing i
loved it i was not scared of
confrontation i was not scared of
yeah like once your
you know your dad walks away from you
it's like yeah what the [ __ ] are you
unless you have a gun or a knife what
are you gonna do and even then
no no no no
listen i'm running if i see a gun i'm
running zigzag i've had them both
i've had the the knife one
wasn't me
it was my friend was having a fair fight
with a friend
and um
she pulled the knife and i was like no
no
we're not doing knives and she's like
[ __ ] she started to come at me okay
but she don't know that i grew up around
cause i'm out of my neighborhood i'm now
on second street this is a hundred
percent irish except for one block which
is mixed puerto rican and irish one
block and they're all related
and they already know me so
we you're good i'm good i'm okay this is
this girl and i have already had our
thing
we we had our fight so we you know we
know where we are with one another kind
of thing so i was like nah you're not
pulling a knife on her and she came
after me and she don't know in my
neighborhood i have a lot of
they used to say there's something in
the water in our neighborhood water that
that that we we bre we put out the most
the craziest of south philly came from
this neighborhood and this guy patty
used to teach me how to take knives off
people no just because we were bored
13 years old he's like all right i'm
coming at you what do you do
so he would do it to me and i'd be like
oh you know and i'm like damn
no no i look like edward scissorhands
because i got cuts all over i'm trying
to take this knife i'm learning
but now flash two
it could have been a year or two later
this girl pulls a knife and i'm like no
no
patty catlin taught me this
and i took it off her and she was just
like
and we became instant friends
really it's the tightest tightest
one of my best friends unfortunately
she's doing life in prison
she did not work
where i thought that was gonna go she
did not learn from that mistake she did
not
sounds like she might have took that
knife back you know
she came from one of the craziest
families are you still in touch with her
no no no we all lost touch with her
everybody asked and i what happened i
have no idea you really don't know why
she started
i i lost contact with her all before
that yeah and and then
everybody was just looking you know how
the facebook the social media taking her
away from you
social media all that [ __ ] people are
like where is this person where is the
person we thought she was dead yeah
because it was a lot
and her brothers were bad and in and out
of jail and
i think there's only one left out of
them
and like left alive
damn yeah they were crazy god bless them
but they loved me so i was like allies
in this [ __ ] and um
but she if somebody found out that she
was in prison and i was like
okay that
that at least we know she's not past but
whatever who knows now i haven't heard
in years that was
15 years ago that i found that out maybe
even more and uh i have another guy
friend that i grew up with
um nikki who's doing life in prison as
well do you see in touch with him at all
no no no we lost contact um
he went in early he went in when we were
still like in the neighborhood kind of
thing
uh
or maybe i had just moved to la because
i moved to la when i was 21. so
maybe i had just moved out here and then
i found out a little bit later he was
doing life but we were all they were all
still trying to help him like he would
go in and out of prison he had no
parents i don't know where his parents
were
and like we would go to his house he
they had money
and so the neighbors would check on him
and
we would do the craziest [ __ ] with him
and his neighbor
his neighbor was even
more insane his father was in the mob
or something like that lone shark i'm
not sure exactly what happened but his
neighbor was in the mob
and um when his father was locked up his
neighbor stevie went
rented a helicopter and tried to take
his father out of prison
get the [ __ ] i swear to god you can look
it up
they thought they were gonna airlift his
hands out of prison i mean they'll shoot
that [ __ ]
so stevie was crazy did they actually go
through with this or he got busted they
got busted they got it in the air and
everybody got it in the air they got it
close to
and it got bad and it
stevie was the one with the cars so he
had that kind of money so we were little
and i'd be like wedged in the back of
this or going on a crazy trans am test
drive you know t tops off you know but i
i was
my brothers were more in with him like i
was
kind of like this dirty little girl was
like who's that it's like oh well she
can break into anything so whatever you
need her for she's cool
but my close friend became stevie's
best friend
and then when he went to jail i don't
know if it was after the helicopter
incident or
i can't he was crazy yeah we used to say
he was a cat because he had nine lives
he had a motorcycle accident on broad
street and him and the girl were drugged
straight up the street and his whole
chest was ripped off [ __ ] chest she
survived as well his titties were a
little smaller than yours
if you can believe it
remember this stevie
you know i
listen
oh i'm used to the and by the way
wearing a sports bra and
why how does she not get laid
because no gender knows which one she is
is that caitlyn caitlin is that you
uh
so
i remember so he had some crazy
incidents but one of
the worst things with him was when he
went to jail not not my friend nikki
this nikki i was closer with because we
used to have stealing contests me and
nicky we were tight yeah you just said i
want to talk about breaking into [ __ ]
and stuff after this so get i want to
hear this first so
um
so stevie and my buddy richie became
real tight real real tight and um they
were like inseparable and
he was
a little older than us stevie but um
richie and i were the same age and
he one day i
his dad was a
a fireman or something
and they used to hang at this bar
like right outside right across the
street from richie's house and so he um
they go to the bar like they would come
in and out of this bar a lot and i was
walking down the street and i saw them
running out of this bar and then all of
a sudden
uh it was like a ton of people out and
they were by um this truck a pickup
truck that the dad had and so i was like
what the hell that's that's richie's dad
you know and i i walk over and they open
the door and it's richie on the front
seat
with two bullets in the back of his head
and money stuffed in his mouth no
and i was like and i think i was
50 you saw this i saw them open the door
i saw everybody was gathered
apparently the car was running it was a
hit it was quick it was whatever the
money is the money in the mouth is don't
rat
you they thought he was going to rat he
didn't rat because when stevie went in
who took the money this was his cl this
is philly i was thinking of it i gotta
be honest somebody took that money
i was like that's a lot of how much
i don't know i'll take that blood i
don't know but it was i remember going
to his funeral that's what that meant
i'm sorry yeah that means you're gonna
wrap or
you're thinking
that's how they're letting everybody
notice the reason this dude's dead is
he's arrested
yeah so i've never heard that one before
yeah is that an old school mob thing
i've never heard that one they didn't
let me in because i'm irish but uh
but i i do remember
being like what's with all the money and
that's i found out but i was 15 i think
and the only reason i'm
crazy i'm your first dead body
no no
first
first friend friend dead body dead body
you know they used to joke want to see
fat larry in the trunk no i don't want
to see fat ladies
you saw a dead body before that mm-hmm
and like what in the name in a trunk
yeah like i was like yeah that was a
thing it was all mob it was all mob run
you'd see a car on fire a person in it
you know in it in it yeah it was all mob
run it was you know we were just
one of the kids i used to date um well
it wasn't dated we were in third grade
like what
who wants to get in this communion dress
you know
look at this
wink wink you know like i was a little
help but this kid that um i was
kind of dating
whatever you call it at that age we were
walking his dad's house
in this place packer park which we call
the suburbs d'amira coined it as the
suburbs of south philly but it was we
never called it that because we were
like it's still the houses were way
bigger and more expensive but you had to
go under the tunnel like under the
bridge to go into that neighborhood we
were on the other side so it's weird
because that neighborhood's there then
our neighborhood then the playground
then the project so it's like it's like
a third world country like what where is
this is
there's i don't know what middle class i
don't know what anything is we just we
know that's where the money is that area
so we would go into pack a part we were
walking to packer park where his dad
lived and as we were walking up the
house blew up
the house blew up his father's house
what are you talking about the house
you're walking too yeah you could have
been in there [ __ ] his dad you could
have been in there there was six of us
on the way total six of you
i don't know what do you give a [ __ ]
about kids or anything i i mean they
wouldn't know their parents were
separated so he was
you know staying with his mom
on uh ninth street so this was in our
neighborhood you know when parents split
up how close you to that 100 yards how
close uh maybe maybe yeah we were at the
tunnel we could see the smoke yeah
we were probably a hundred yards
it's so insane yeah it's just burning
when you get there
bernie but main concern was his dad not
being in there right so if we were still
like in shock and
it was we were with his cousin i wonder
you're so [ __ ] angry maybe that's
what i'm saying i'm all upbringing
that's just the house so is it because
we were outside like people are like you
know
you learn uh
like racism they they teach that at home
right yeah that's that's in the home and
that's it that is a thing but i learned
it on the street because when if i came
home and said
say i dropped an m-bomb or said
something negative about black kids or
whatever
my mother would flip out and beat the
[ __ ] out of us but what i didn't know is
sh she learned it because her grandma
learned it so it was passed down she
learned to say certain things that she
didn't realize were racist because they
weren't around
there wasn't a lot of black people in
their neighborhood the people that were
in the projects were the irish kids at
that point when she was growing up
you know they were just trying to come
out they were the ones trying to get out
of the projects whatever so
uh that was completely all white
but irish you know i guess if you're
gonna label where they were from and so
um they didn't know from
that but my grandma heard these words
and they were racist words and then my
mom went to work and said them
through
a horrible it's a i can't do it because
it's an n-bomb but she didn't know
and she so you know when you get like my
mother's gonna kill me if my brother
tommy finds this and plays this for her
i'm in big trouble
i'm sorry for this story
is there a warning no i'm kidding no so
you know what you sweat
and you get like right here it gets like
little when you're a kid dirt line right
yeah there you go what you call it a
dirt line that's not what they called it
you like it you got it got it
so
that's not what they come and my mother
grew up
saying that
no clue
of who it was offending or where it came
from no clue i don't even think my
grandmom did i gotta be honest so
because they were just struggling in
their own existence so they they weren't
rich kids they weren't you know they
lived in a neighborhood my mom said she
wasn't allowed to go on 15th street
because that's where all the drunken
sailors were
that's the the navy
that's where they used to house them but
these guys would be on leave or whatever
and get drunk
and
it could be a fight it could be
rape it could be kid it could be all
kinds of [ __ ] so my mom wasn't allowed
that's all she remembered you know and
so she wasn't racist so she's at work
she's sitting with her black co-worker
and she goes oh no
no
that lady what did she do fight her what
she went that's a excuse that's a
phillies black lady
my mother was like
the most naive sweet woman you'd ever
meet not a bad word to say about anybody
says that the lady goes excuse me
and my mother goes
yeah what do you call it and she went
dirt
and my poor sweet mother
was like oh my god
and
dirt they became
instant friends lifelong friends
i'm serious my mom invited her for
dinner she was like there's one
right there you have to i didn't know
i did not know
that
no her mother we don't know [ __ ] about
this
oh god
we didn't know [ __ ] about this
so she had this woman come over for
dinner
this was from her job this was before
she had kids this is
she worked at the quartermasters oh i
see so this is before
she had kids so we weren't even in
existence
this is how young she is this is why she
was also so strict and stern the horror
perception because she was like uh i did
not know that
because yeah it's learned out but so i
wasn't we weren't allowed to talk any of
that like we were
whatever but in the streets it was on
you know we were whoever we were mad at
was who we were cursing and
saying whatever slurs and that went for
irish polis polish italian can't even
say polish that's how bad they are
anyway
you know it went for everybody you got
labeled for what your nationality was
it's it's isn't it interesting because
there was a time when we grew up where
there were pollock jokes 100 percent my
dad will still tell people 100 of them
i never understood why they were sort of
the scapegoat of earth you know what i
mean like they just made polish to be
the idiots you know what i mean they
just chose them have you met him i'm
kidding
that's what my dad would say let me
introduce you to glenn i'm like dad
that's rude he's right here i talked to
about uh we had a restaurant there's
still i think it's still there in
baltimore but it's called pollock
johnny's it's uh oh yeah we have pollock
right it's a it's a hot a killer hot dog
place
and so i'm at work this is this is
probably like early 2000s and i was
talking about this restaurant i say i'm
looking at this writing gig and i'm like
oh yeah polo chinese like what'd you
just say i'm like she's like that's
racist i'm like
you might be right but not in this name
google it and i'm like here here's the
restaurant it's called pollock johnny
the sign's all over it maybe he's polish
or the original owner was and he took it
as an affectionate way to say it but i'm
just telling you me
are you telling me i can't go eat at
that restaurant because he's racist or
are you telling me i can eat there but i
just can't say the goddamn name of it
because it's a great yeah
can i have their chili dog yeah see
that's a thing
people own it where i come from yeah you
know
and
my grandmother just say it all the time
they're all italian and they would call
themselves names all the time but that's
where my whole
that's what i'm saying you're very i'm
kidding you're very much like my family
like we're ball busters we call it
what we see it now coming out here
that's an [ __ ] how many times and and
you say that to a regular person like
[ __ ] you know i'm like what what did
i say
what's wrong is that we we also say it
in like the form of a sentence like what
are you a jerk yeah yeah yeah
let me think about that am i a jerk off
you know like
we say we my sister affectionate where i
come from if somebody says listen
[ __ ] oh they love me they want me to
hear what they have to say
we're having a conversation
i'm apologize if you've i've asked you
and you've said it because we've done a
few episodes together now have you been
arrested
yes but did we talk about it
uh mostly for fighting never for never
for theft no
all right theft was just they would call
cause it was dumb [ __ ] so what's the
first thing you remember stealing
do you know um
no not the actual first thing but i
remember with my friend nikki
who's doing life
we had a competition
in their neighborhood which is the rich
neighborhood they had a big supermarket
and we went in it was me
nikki charlie
my brother billy
probably chris two both two chris's i'm
not gonna say the last things um yeah
don't call them out i'm good you said
that and they're still my closest
friends
so i i okay probably them and we went in
and we were like and of course i'm the
only girl i'm always the only girl just
the dirty girl who's ready to fight at
any moment and
whatever are you also the youngest
always too or i was younger
yeah because billy's a year older but
like a year
you know nothing crazy like
was nikki my age he might have been my
age i forget
but
we because i don't remember him from
school he didn't go to school he was a
he was a bad kid he didn't go to school
with us he was a kid we hung out with i
don't even know if he went to school i
got to be honest but he was just always
around
and so
we go to um and his parents owned a
convenience store so we would go in
there until they both went in
and then
or something and that's when he had no
parents and so um and now he's serving
life
see this makes me feel good i had no
parents and i'm sitting right here with
you god bless i'm sitting right here see
that you had no parents no and from 16
on i had no parents wow who no
well we lived on our own from 16 to 18.
at 18 my mom kicked us out of the house
where we're in even though she would
stay with her boyfriend we went my
brother and i went and lived my younger
brother stayed with her my brother and i
went live with my grandmom but for
a year and a half and then she dropped
dead in front of us
in front of you
i gave her cpr and all that [ __ ]
so at the top of the stairs of that
[ __ ] row home in baltimore yes and
right in front of that goddamn little
bathroom oh yeah
right there at the top of the landing
was the bathroom her bedroom was right
there there was a hallway
i was going to say did she have a
hallway
was a banister so you didn't fall over
the [ __ ] stairs coming up and then
there was this room in this room where i
stayed yeah and i would have a twin i
had a twin bed and a dresser and i'd
have to turn sideways to get in that
[ __ ] same with the middle room
see we didn't have the narrow hallway it
wasn't a high high it was always jealous
of that yeah it's like a vestibule it's
like a
short 10 feet long before a door yeah
okay yeah
yeah so we
we
my friend melissa had that and i was
always jealous like look at this and i
lived in the basement for a while too
like tricked that out a little bit okay
yeah from then i had no real nothing and
you and you should you have a brother a
sister two brothers two brothers younger
brother and a twin brother and what did
she what did she
go down from a heart attack my dad died
of a heart attack my grandma also died
of a heart attack but your your mom you
said she dropped dead in front of you no
my grandmom did oh you're great so my
mom
still alive
um my dad died of a heart attack we
found him in his bed in the morning then
then we lived on our own from 16 to 18
in this apartment where my mother
had it but she stayed she lived at her
boyfriend okay so we were alone monday
through saturday she'd come home sunday
for a couple hours do laundry and bounce
wow and the three of us raised each
other and then at 18 she stopped getting
a check because we were minors when my
father died and at 18 she kicked us out
because she no longer got the money and
my grandmom said you can come stay with
me
but only a year not even a year and a
half into that she dropped dead oh geez
and then it was
dunnsville for good it's easy but no net
sense eleanor see that look at you you
have any arrests
none muzzle and i'm not i'm almost 50
i'm not doing okay good for you yeah i
could have been a statistic i wanted to
be a different statistician listen this
statistic was one of my favorite
statistics for a long period of time
uh like when we did the so we had this
competition who could steal the most out
of this
we knew where the manager was and i mean
we cased the joint we went in
and i thought all right oh charlie was
with us i say charlie was with us
charlie was with us
so me charlie and billy were together a
lot until charlie started like i mean he
was older than us and he started growing
his hair long and listening to the rock
music and then
billy and him
part of wait like hey man that's not
cool we listened to rick james in this
[ __ ] you know like
so whatever uh it was just a you know he
growing up and grown past us so
but this time charlie was with us and he
was pretty good at stealing too so i
was like how am i going to win this
company it's got to be about how much
things are right
so i stole cigarettes
and i'm nine
at this point and i i lined my
waist
with cartons of cigarettes that was when
it was open yeah how old i am
no no i remember i talked about my buddy
had the best move
he would grab two
walk around a 7-11 buy a big gulp and
then you know out loud but you know what
i'm not going to get these and put them
back but he would keep one he always
grabbed two kept one it worked every
[ __ ] time and then they started
locking them up behind them oh yeah well
i i may have been the reason they
brought the locks in you [ __ ] had how
did how would you do it and how old are
you how old are we talking about that
and i put them in the elastic in my
shorts like all the way around your
words
titles had box tits no i'm just kidding
i had a
it may have been like
spring-ish because or fall-ish it depend
but for some reason i had a bigger shirt
like a sweatshirt of sorts or whatever
and so i was able to
hide them
and
uh
we go out
and charlie's like what you get
everybody's out you know what you get
what you get
and i'm like just keep walking just keep
walking you know and behind this there's
really nothing because the navy
shipyards up there you're all together
so you just made a hit on that little
[ __ ]
yeah it's a big hit and it's a lot of
money because the cigarettes were
jumping up and pray not a lot but like
you know it's going to be more than a
snickers bar yeah or whatever you steal
so i'm like and a carton's what 20 packs
uh 10 10 i believe so it was probably 20
back then which is what people would
kill for now oh yeah and so but i was
like okay i'm adding maybe it was 15 or
20 i forget but i remember being a big
number and to us it was like oh my god
so
i'm walking out and so behind this
supermarket you can run all the way up
broad street to
a place we call down the lakes which i
just as an adult found out that's fdr
park no idea anyway
uh so um i don't pay attention we call
it down the lakes i don't even know if
there's a lake in there i gotta be on no
there's a lake but we would go down
there right and nobody's down there so
that's where we're gonna
open our stuff so we have a
good
uh almost a half a mile to run to this
place
and so i'm walking i'm nervous and i'm i
go wait wait where's nikki and nobody's
showing what they have because they're
wait and we're like where's nicky
there's nicki and we're walking walking
and out of nowhere we hear
go
and we're like we turn this [ __ ]
had a grocery cart
filled
it it curved
it was
and he's running and things are flying
off he's got the stolen [ __ ]
[ __ ] party too right with the cart
and this is the 80s toll and they don't
have those things it's not quiet
yeah
i mean we ran we were soaking wet hiding
and now half his car is going but he's
still this [ __ ] beat me yeah
yeah cause he's got a cart so i was
pissed they're like what did you get i'm
like yo you take a cart that's cheating
the whole [ __ ] car we're gonna get a
rest you know and i'm flipping out what
did you get i'm like i got cigarettes
they're like what are we gonna do with
those i'm like i guess smoke them and
that's how i started smoking oh is it
really that's how you started that's
terrible
you still see your hands and started
like we had a hideout
it had food and cigarettes in there oh
and we would go all the way down the
lakes to have food and cigarettes and
you know our little that was our little
cubby hole if you will where we hit our
[ __ ]
so i got hooked too smoking what about
stealing did you get hooked on the
stealing did you like that no i hated it
and what i think i remember the last
thing i stole
i was in high school
and
i
i guess it was like makeup of some sort
maybe mascara i'm not sure and i put it
up my sleeve you know and my friend kim
was with me
and
you know she was doing it too
throwing things in her pocket a little
like a little five finger
all of us were poor whatever so we're
just not that's an excuse because
after this thing i never stole again so
i get caught and they go we're going to
call your house you know we're calling
your mother and i go go ahead
here's the number because
here's what the kerrigans did
my mom was always working somebody had
to make money
so we'd get a phone call and be like
yeah i'm mrs carrigan or yes i'm mr
kerrigan whatever it was and we'd so
even though maybe you all went your
separate ways everyone was on the same
page when it came to a call at the house
100 you're mister or mrs character take
it don't [ __ ] rat us out nobody rats
i think i told you in the head and a
[ __ ] wad of money in your mouth that
i didn't learn until later but before
that um they hung me over the banister
upside down because i who did my
brothers
why would you tell them because i was
gonna tell i was going to tell my father
something i think i was six and they
they held me up and they get this what
you get for rat and that's what rats get
i was like
i think my parents could see my fingers
coming out like
[ __ ] it was bad it is wrong they were
like you
and so i never rat you never rat they
they taught us in the house that i did
learn at home
and so
we would always you know
back each other edie got caught stealing
we
yes i'm mrs carrigan i go pick her up
you know
i'm my mom stuck with a baby at the
house so she sent me
and she is in big trouble you know the
whole thing okay they let her go and
again this is we were young we were so
young so
um
this time when i saw i was in high
school
and they called my mother
guess who didn't go to work that day nah
that's the only reason i
i mean i was white as a ghost like oh
[ __ ]
i don't know why she was home i don't
remember her being home i think she got
sick at work and came home so now
she has to get on a bus
and come up because she don't drive and
come all the way up broad street and
pick up
jackass number eight
for stealing and then on the way home
gives what i call the worst lecture ever
about stealing and and then the
is it because i don't give you enough
we don't know
now here comes yeah all right yeah you
know when i cry it's like a dude crying
because
it don't happen
turn them in i'm i'm cold
and so when i'm
i'm like this jesus is hitting you heavy
huh here she goes right and i
i mean i can remember the words and
start crying right now like it's
it's what we call an actual
sense memory yeah how old uh
14 and you remember everything every
word on the bus
the money she had to use to get to the
bus what a call how much was it called
how much i don't know was it 50 cents 75
cents but that's a lifetime for my
mother you know that's this is a woman
who take all the bills back because my
dad wouldn't pay them
and in fact when richie's
my friend's funeral
our lights were out and i was 15. we
have no lights really and i couldn't
find a shirt and i wound up i couldn't
see in the dark and i'm going through i
mean you got to imagine there's all
these kids up in this the piles of
clothes
piles of cl like where's mine
where's my shirt and i we all our stuff
was together nothing was separate oh
really yeah it took us long to get ready
like the older kids would cut theirs you
know
my brother jimmy bought a big trunk i
remember his trunk we used to break in
it all the time and steal his change
anyway he's like i'll [ __ ] kill you
kids
but he would put his clothes in there
nice things he didn't want us wearing
and he would lock
like it was it was like a workplace you
know you have to lock your [ __ ] up if
you want to keep it and so
uh i was looking and looking and i
remember i went out and i as i got out
as i got to the church and thank god i
had a jacket on it was a pink and black
shirt
to a to a memorial to a viewing yeah and
i was like [ __ ]
and i remember being so embarrassed
because i had to get ready in the dark
the lights are all the lights are off
it's you know and oh man and it was the
fall so it got dark earlier you know
and i i i i have such a vivid memory
of everything from that from stevie
being there from his girlfriend nicole
who was in the car a bike accident with
him and
i mean i'm sorry not stevie stevie's
girlfriend being there and stevie's
family like cousins and stuff that i
knew because stevie was in jail at this
point oh he was yeah because they
thought richie was gonna
rat on like things he they thought he
knew too much
so they assumed he was gonna rap but he
wouldn't do that you know and he was
very young so he could have been
uh
what do you call it maybe cohort coheres
out of information you know he was
15 16.
that's all right so what are you doing
as a kid that's a kid what are you doing
to um
to work on your anger and [ __ ] do you do
you go to therapy therapy no you do work
out
i have to work out i do a lot of calm
you down running um will calm me down uh
anything like bike ride i'll ride my
bike box or anything like that no i'm
afraid i did that before me and my buddy
rock yeah cause i get like if i get hit
i react we here's the thing
like rocco was like no we'll spar and
i'm like i don't i don't think you want
to do that
it's like the ferrigno you wouldn't like
me when i made it yeah i mean but you
people are sitting there listening to
you right now they forget you used to
wrestle oh yeah you go back see if you
go back and listen to the episodes you
were in was it glow no that's rude
i like it but no that means it looked
good it was glow
earlier
i think you know i was still robbing
supermarkets no i'm kidding
what was your league again
so it was wow women of wrestling wow and
i did um i played easy rider
and so easy rider was uh
and then i went back and did commentary
for them
about four years ago five years ago so i
still work for a while yeah they're
still around whale is amazing um the
girls now i think wrestle i mean they're
good are they insane like doing just
sick [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] yeah that's
what but here's the thing like we got
cast as actors
to play almost like the show glow you
know the marin that one
like when i watched that i thought oh
that's what happened to me it was an
audition and i was like i'm down on my
luck
and i did it and i got the job
and
when i started wrestling i was like oh
[ __ ] now i gotta really wrestle but that
got that was good because you're not
hitting you know certain times
yeah of course you get hit sure i got
hurt i had a hairline fracture my
collarbone i
busted my pinky
broke my pinky because selena who was
training us with the mullet she was the
best selena majors a phenomenal
phenomenal wrestler who wrestled in
japan and wrestled for years knew every
knows every wrestler and is well
respected by all of them she was our
trainer selena and peggy lee leather
well
that was her name before she became my
uh peggy um harley's angel she was our
gang leader
oh no wait peggy leather was what we
called her oh [ __ ] what was her famous
name before that
i forget what i'm messing i'm mixing
them up but peggy um she's also
phenomenal and her and selena wrestled
for years on the road and so she taught
us a lot but selena was busy training
everybody else
and one of the matches was supposed to
be her and i the story line is she has
to fight
uh me and my partner charlie davidson
charlie they gave me a partnership
of all the goddamn names the world could
pick
they give you the one that you say
charlie
tell them charlie if you watch old clips
of wow
you'll hear me talking [ __ ] cause that's
what i got hired for talking [ __ ]
i'm talking [ __ ] on the mic and then i
go tell him charlie and i throw the mic
down like why
and so and whatever so it's ch um easy
rider she's charlie davidson and then
peggy was our gang leader so in order
for selena to fight peggy she had to
fight both of us separately so selena's
doing everything she's training
everybody and doing everybody's matches
right so
i said hey selena this is odd but
our fight's tomorrow night i don't know
what the match is she goes don't worry
easy i'm gonna call it
i'm i'm sorry what was that
she goes i'm gonna call it and i'm like
you're gonna call what and she goes i'm
gonna whisper in your ear
what moves to do
i swear
you're going into a match bla just blind
and she's going to whisper every move
yes watch the match
ah you can see it it's it's not even
selena major's first easy rider it is or
hilarious do you hear her saying it no
no we're at the forum in englewood
packed
jam was it really packed you wrestled in
the forum an inglewood so exciting
so exciting and some of the older guys
used to come and see us you know i met a
lot of people there you know because
they were friendly with selena and peggy
so
it was exciting i met sergeant slaughter
you know like killer like
so i you know i'm and i have to wrestle
in jeans so it's already a thousand
degrees right my hair is stuck to my
head i got all this makeup on i'm
dressed like a biker chick and
so i'm in the corner and selena gave me
this one like thing that i used to do
and
you know it became like a joke she the
bronco buster was one of my moves right
i didn't know you know she's she's gay
and she likes me to bounce my [ __ ] on
her chest so i'm just kidding i love you
selina
but we would tease about it we got so
close that we would tease about it you
know like whatever so but that's
basically what it is you're pouncing on
this person's chest so
that was definitely gonna be in there so
i knew certain
things i just didn't know when
you know and so there's we start off
lock up you know and she looks and she
goes okay you know and she calls it
and i'm like what what as i'm getting
clotheslined right and i went everything
to in wrestling is to the left right
because is that right if your right hand
most people are right-handed okay so if
you go to the left you're not going to
hurt the person as much
so i
i i'm like what you say i'm on the wrong
side so i get knocked the [ __ ] out baby
like i got hit hard and i'm like oh
they're like that was an amazing bump
and i'm like no she's dead i'm dead you
know that hurt and i'm like [ __ ] and
part of me wants to hit her because of
my anger and i'm like no you this is a
this is you know it can't be hawk hogan
and rocky you know they don't know you
just pay attention and so i'm like oh my
god you know and uh so i'm trying i'm
trying i got a little bit here and there
and then she hits me with a [ __ ]
chair
and i
are you serious i panic and i go what
the [ __ ] you know and that's how i broke
my pinky
because i go to grab it like i'm going
to hit you with the chair oh you want to
hit the chair oh patty catlin he taught
me how to take knives off people you
know i'm like i'm pulling i'm so that's
how i broke my pinky and she was like
easy you know like but the match is
hilarious and it has some of my my
favorite still
pictures from because she the sunset
flip was a thing i would do all the time
so she pulls me in and my hair just goes
all up in the air and i just flip and
fly at least like all the way to the
other side of the ring because i was
that was my thing i i was a good um
victim whatever like opponent because i
would play dead and i could fly you know
so
she flips me over and there's a great
picture of her pulling me and my hair in
the air like midair and her muscles and
mullet just out and about i love that
you did that
but yeah that was the scariest but
what i'm saying is like when you get hit
and hurt like with the boxing if
somebody hurts me i don't know what'll
happen like you're no longer gonna box
you're just gonna [ __ ] i'm scared
yeah so i don't i have that thing where
i lose it and i i'm not just training on
a bag then i could do that yeah i can do
that yeah because hurting myself is
great i love that
but my brother jimmy um
he you know the older half took care of
the younger half with us
so
jimmy um i remember he was on the phone
with his girlfriend we always talk about
this story because it's like this
it's one of the scariest that happened
in our house and there was some scary
[ __ ] so
my brother billy
jimmy was telling us what to do
and we you know we were kind of growing
you know like he told us what to do you
know we're 11 and 12 like we [ __ ]
know we're doing you know
idiots and jimmy's our older brother
he's nine he's eight years older than me
so
billy's older than me so he's seven
years older than billy so billy's [ __ ]
you you know and he throws the frisbee
and now jimmy's very tough uncomfortably
tough he throws the frisbee hits jimmy
in the face and he goes
[ __ ] because he's on the phone
with his girlfriend he goes [ __ ]
and knocks it down and he gives billy a
look so he's like yeah yeah and then he
touched his lip
and it was bleeding i i swear he went
like that like and then
the phone he didn't hang it up he just
dropped it and the rage
me and charlie had to go get
a neighbor
i'm not kidding to get him off of his
own brother he was and i mean
beating
and we we got another like one of the
toughest guys in the neighborhood this
guy georgie martin got arrested so
george we had georgie come in and take
him off and jimmy was like
you know like there's the only person
that could stop jimmy and georgie i
remember him pulling him and saying jim
look at me look at me it's your brother
that's your little brother
it was but we we go
when we go let your little brother
[ __ ]
i don't go to the beach i don't go to
the beach
i've never seen him throw a frisbee
[Laughter]
yeah i don't even know why we had a
frisbee but i guess you know we played
frisbee at some point you're the best
listen thank you for coming i love it
this is the best thank you for doing
audio in my kitchen when we first
started this podcast oh my god that's
thank you for coming back i love how
it's grown this is amazing
um please promote everything whatever
again plug it all in websites all that
stuff i will uh i should look up those
dates with holtzman because look it up
that's exciting but um
i am uh in lahore it's your website do
you have it on your website jay kerrigan
yeah eleanor kerrigan do you put it on
your website you said you're i know you
gotta bang a millennial so you get those
dates up here's the thing i tried to
update on this website and i had a
nervous breakdown so i called my friend
ari and ari was gonna help me but ari
was busy with his podcast so he couldn't
help me and then he learned how to do it
in a second and he's like i'll just show
you but i had to go on the road and i
left for 20 days and i did my album my
album is coming out there you go in the
summer there you go all right and so in
the summer
uh look for an album i'm excited about
this it's my first ever and i did it in
jersey to um you know capacity so
i tease dice and say this is my day the
laughter die because there's nobody
there um
there's like 20 people so
um but yeah so may um
21st 22nd 23rd i'm in la jolla at the
comedy store and then um
june
june 24th through 27th i will be with
the great brian holtzman at the laugh
actually
the silver legacy and reno and then i
have a bunch more dates and i promise
i'll update them all right i will sleep
with ari to get it yes not shafir it's a
different one thank god a lot of jews
were named mari anyway
more racism
i love you uh as always ryan sickler.com
ryan sickler on all social media we'll
talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]